[Music]
while plenty of games have a level
creator mode of some type Nintendo Super
Mario maker for Wii U takes that idea to
a whole new level the entire game is
built around creating and sharing your
own 2d Mario stages and with a seamless
intuitive design Mario maker can help
even the most talent 'less creators like
me feel like they could be an actual
designer in the Creator part of Mario
maker you crib elements from several
Mario games and toss them together into
a level of your own making that you then
upload online for everyone else to play
you choose the overall graphical skin
from among several classical Mario games
which affects the way everything looks
sounds and some of the available items
for example the cape feather and Mario
world is swapped out for the propeller
and new super mario brothers you and the
background that you choose airship
underwater a castle etc determines the
stage and musical themes the
mix-and-match nature allows for
anachronistic additions to familiar
scenes like a giant Koopa with a cannon
firing Chain Chomp strapped to its back
[Music]
it's a simple drag-and-drop system and
the hand representing your on-screen
stylus can be swapped to represent
lefties righties different skin tones or
even a cat paw and creating scenery and
platforms is as easy as dragging your
stylus across the level as you place two
obstacles and platforms little
background elements pop up adding color
and variety you can even drop in
pre-recorded sound and visual effects to
your stages like a beating heart to add
some tension to an ominous dungeon
hallway and with an undo dog button and
a restart rocket icon the menu aesthetic
is an obvious nod to the quirky
experimental SNES title Mario Paint
everything is incredibly easy to
understand to implement and experiment
with which makes creating levels even
for a complete novice fun and effortless
experimenting with the creation tools
and playing around with the maker aspect
is fun on its own but you really learn
to use those tools through trying out
levels Mario maker comes with a suite of
pre-built stages but the user created
levels are where the real genius and
maddening difficulty come in the game
makes it easy to find and sort user
created levels by popularity difficulty
and creator
but the force that keeps driving you
through these player-created levels no
matter how crazy is knowing that someone
had to beat them to upload them they
might seem unbelievably unfair but
someone beat that level at least once
and that means you can too and those
broad strokes don't even go into things
like the music from the familiar themes
of the main world's to the altered riffs
you get when tinkering around in make
mode the soundtrack captures the same
essence of Wonder and surprise as the
rest of the game even the in-game
instruction manual is incredibly useful
and entertaining
it's graphically animated written with a
great sense of humor and for no
particular reason throws in some
thoughts about Brussels sprouts Super
Mario maker is a game of joyous creation
and fun surprises and for the first time
in a creation focus game I look forward
to returning again and again not just
for the amazing levels I know other
people will create but to keep trying to
make my own levels better the game won't
necessarily turn you into the next
Shigeru Miyamoto but you can almost feel
a little bit of that magic rubbing off
every time you upload a new creation
[Music]
[Music]